tonight University Bookstore is very
pleased to welcome peel surprise winner
David McCumber managing editor at the
Seattle post-intelligencer to talk about
he and former PR reporter Andrew
Schneider's book and air The Kills how
asbestos put at the asbestos poisoning
of Libby Montana uncovered a national
scandal for 60 years the grace
corporation blanketed a small Montana
town and a poison dust sickening a
significant number of its own citizens
and all of it would have remained
covered up had it not been for the
investigative work of encumbrance Neider
in there that kills is an expose of
corporate negligence and example of the
Free Press at its most relevant and
vital to our lives please welcome David
McCumber thank you thank you very much
Matthew and thank you to University
Bookstore for for having me here I'd
like to correct the record quickly I'm
not a Pulitzer Prize winner My partner
my co-author Andrew Schneider is a
double Pulitzer Prize winner I was a
finalist for one but that's as close as
I ever got I also just have a couple of
other quick thank-yous to make I seen
this how I'm reading reading in my
hometown I have to thank the newspaper I
worked for a Seattle post-intelligencer
for the commitment that they made to
allow us to pursue this story it's an
uncommon commitment in this day and age
this story took 16 months and a great
deal of reporting work and expense and
I'm proud of the pi4 for doing that
I'm also greatly indebted to Andy
Schneider my my co-author can't be here
tonight unfortunately I lost him to the
st. Louis post-dispatch he's an amazing
journalist and people have asked me
about taking on projects like this and
my advice is if you're going to write
a piece of journalism like this try to
do it with a two-time Pulitzer Prize
winner collaboration is never easy but
having a reporter of andis caliber
certainly is a great thing I'm gonna
read the prologue to this book because I
think it says what this books about I
hope as well as I can say it and then
I'll be happy to take some questions and
and any conversation that you guys would
like to indulge in a single lodgepole
pine from what's left of zona light
mountain would be plenty fell it watch
out for the cloud of dust skidded out
peel it rip it into one by fours and
sell it to a survivor of the plague on
this place it doesn't take much lumber
to knock together 200 simple crosses
take them to the body shop prime them
spray them white paint a name in black
on each one that's probably enough for
this year if you don't look too hard
into the past four more names after all
for six decades not one doctor put the
actual words on a death certificate in
Libby Montana asbestos-related disease
but now you're at it don't stop making
crosses the little town of Libby we'll
be needing two or three thousand more
the federal government came in and did
the biggest Public Health Survey in its
history a third of the town got what
Gayla Benefield accurately calls the
death sentence mincing words is not her
style
the town already knows many of the names
that will need to be painted miners sure
some of them men who actually dug the
death out of the mountain hauled it
milled it swept it sacked it breathed it
for two or three bucks an hour and glad
to do it then we're at home on their
clothes men like les skramstad here's
the hard thing many of the miners are
already gone and most of the names still
to be painted are those of their wives
and children and grandchildren still
others on the list have no family
connection no way to know exactly where
or when they inhaled enough of the
that covers Libby to lodge tiny fibers
of tremolite asbestos into their lungs
to start the inexorable process of
inflammation pleural thickening loss of
lung function fluid buildup and slow
suffocation some who might in some
obscene way be considered lucky we'll go
more quickly from lung cancer or
mesothelioma a fancy name for another
kind of death sentence a cancer of the
lining of the lung death followed the
vermiculite
or from zone alight mountain as closely
as the asbestos fibers that contaminated
it followed it far from Libby all across
the country to more than 300 processing
plants and farther yet today in millions
of homes the hazardous material still
rests and attics and walls to be sent
into air and lungs with any disturbance
asbestos from Libya was released into
the air in New York City when the World
Trade Center buildings collapsed nobody
knows how many people have died from it
or where or how many more will die
hundreds of thousands more people will
be exposed to asbestos from other
sources in this country from breaks from
contaminated talc from other sources
from iron ore from all the products
containing asbestos that are still being
legally manufactured and sold because of
the power of an industry here and in
Canada that has lied and covered up for
a deadly century and because of a
government that has not protected us its
workers and consumers in Libya even as
the Environmental Protection Agency
struggles to clean up the toxic mess
some unknown number of the kids who show
no sign of illness now as they ride
their bikes down quiet streets or crowd
boisterously into the Pizza Hut after a
ballgame will die the same way that's
what breaks less skramstad heart and
what makes Gayla Benefield matter than a
stepped on snake strong is a good word
to describe gala picture Nordic blonde
hair fighting the grey and an attractive
functional cut and an expressive mouth
equally comfortable with a smile a kiss
or a swear word I can say [ __ ] you
without moving my lips she says sweetly
pushing her glasses up with an extended
middle thing
her blue eyes betray a quickness of
thought and twinkle as a natural state
of affairs but go cold as Libyan
February when the subject turns to
asbestos for good reason she lost her
mother and father to Libby's curse now
she and her husband David are diagnosed
with the disease 62 members of their
family have either died of the disease
have been diagnosed or remain at high
risk
Gayla was one of the first to fight in
court to get the WR grace company owner
of the vermiculite mine with asbestos in
the or to be found responsible for the
dying after achieving that she has never
stopped fighting for the victims and
their families not for an instant at 67
less skramstad is still trim waisted and
muscular and he still plays country
music around town as he has for 40 years
after he was diagnosed with asbestos in
1996 he became the first former miner to
take grace to trial and win but that
won't keep him alive since his trial he
has learned that his wife Narita and two
of their children have the same disease
that will kill him I loved my job at
Zona light he says quietly each of his
shortening breaths is a gold coin to be
spent wisely and so he was very
soft-spoken even when his jaw sets and
you can see the pain in his eyes I loved
it so much that even if they had told me
I was endangering my life I would
probably have stayed but if they told me
was killing my wife and my family too I
would have run like hell
on this day Memorial Day 2001 gala and
less put aside their anger and
concentrated on honoring the victims
this year for the first time there was
to be a public remembering an
acknowledgement of the many who have
died from asbestos that alone was an
enormous thing for a town that had
suffered in silence for so long a town
literally left to die by every branch of
every government charged with making
sure something like this does not happen
a town that for so many years either did
not know or did not acknowledge what was
killing so many by now the truth was out
unavoidable people around the world knew
about the die
in Libby and so it was only right some
of the survivors decided that the dead
should be honored two men led this
effort Mike Switzer has been diagnosed
with asbestosis his was one of the first
families to settle in Libby more than a
century ago Jim Roscoe has been
diagnosed with asbestosis so I have two
of his brothers and his sister his
effort is most ironic his second cousin
Mark was governor of Montana when the
dying became public knowledge in 1999
Mach Roscoe made concerned noses and did
nothing of substance many of his former
neighbors in Libby say bitterly mike
Switzer and Jim Roscoe got the materials
for the cross has donated they were
built in Libby high school shop class
the painting was done at jeans body shop
and Stephanie berry volunteered to paint
the names some of the local real estate
outfits and others of the Chamber of
Commerce were a little nervous about
putting in the crosses where they'd be
visible to everybody they talked about
putting them behind the Chamber offices
out of the way
Mike Switzer even got a phone call or
two what are you trying to do to our
town Gator went to the City Council one
suggested it would be a good idea to put
the crosses of the cemetery where so
many people from the town of becoming
for Memorial Day the cemetery rests in
bottom land not far off highway 2 behind
the venture in look down and you'll see
a serene sea of grass and marble somehow
uniquely Montana
alum Lewis Kendal born August 3rd 1936
died September 1st 1998 is laid to rest
beneath the epitaph one hell of a man
illustrated by engravings of a piece of
earth-moving equipment and a cowboy on
horseback look up and you'll see
towering sentinels of jack pine and
larch and beyond all along the horizon
the peaks of the cabinet mountains a
wild and spectacular range that
dominates the landscape around Libby but
is only a fingernail on the huge
outstretched hand of the Northern
Rockies many people came to add flowers
to walk among the crosses to read the
names some were carting long green
oxygen tanks by their sides like Don
Kading who said cheerfully well my name
might be here next year
it would be pastor cam foot of the Troy
Baptist Church who played baseball with
galas son at and at 35 has been
diagnosed with asbestosis conducted a
short prayer service then less read the
list of asbestos dead look at Libby look
at the scar of mining against the
landscape look at the working men's
houses where to this day tiny spears of
asbestos hover in the air like a judge's
sentence look at the people who walk to
the post office with slow shuffling
steps rolling what's left of their lives
beside them in the green tanks look at
this piece of ground filled with simple
white crosses and you can almost hear
Maybelle Carter and Johnny Cash singing
one of lesses favorite songs Undertaker
Undertaker Undertaker please drive slow
for that lady that's her Holland Lord I
hate to see her go what can I tell you
about this project
yeah how did you initially find out
about it well you know it was a it's
kind of a fluke and kind of not a fluke
the way it works seems like in
journalism often you're chasing one good
story and one story leads to another
story and we had been spending in the
summer of 1999 we'd been working for
about six months on a project on
hardrock mining and looking at mining on
public lands and and what sort of damage
was being done and and the fact that
there were billions of dollars in gold
sort of going out of the out of the
nation's public lands too too often to
multinational corporations so forth so
we've gone around the nine different
states in the West chasing the story in
Montana was the last one and we had a
photographer and two reporters in the
state and they happen to hear something
while they were working on the hardrock
story about another mine and up in Libby
where there some people might be sick so
I get a call saying well it's a 200 mile
detour and and it's not the story we
came to get but I want to go look at it
and so thanks to Andy Snyder's
persistence he went and looked and the
more he looked the more I just didn't
seem right we couldn't we couldn't
believe that a story of this size hadn't
been reported that nobody knew about it
and the more we looked at it the more we
realized that there had been an active
conspiracy of silence on the part of the
companies that ran a mine and and people
just knew then in the little town and
some of the people who worked at the
mine got sick and nobody looked any
farther than that the medical community
hadn't raised the alarm
so more we looked more we found and it
led us on on quite a chase
6,000 it's a mineral you know in this
case it's it's what they call a [ __ ]
mineral or a contaminant of this other
or the the vermiculite is what they were
mining they weren't mining asbestos they
were minding for make you light but in a
lot of places just geologically for a
Mickey light and tremolite asbestos are
found together and as a matter of fact
there's a for make you light mine going
full-bore right now in Virginia that is
contaminated with asbestos it's another
little Libby happening right now it just
happens to be that way geologically yeah
so my question was how they were able to
keep it quiet for so long Wayne and the
rest of the world in 1970 in the late
nineteen seventies in the rest of the
world asbestos mines were closed but I
think you answered it my thing was
really well there's a couple things to
think about here one is is in Libby
itself the medical community you know
people who didn't even smoke we're told
that they were sick because of smoking
you know people would who had asbestosis
would get pneumonia every year and
they're going into the hospital and
they'd be treated for their pneumonia
and they'd be sent home with no no
diagnosis of the underlying disease now
the one thing in the doctor's favor is
if you think about it historically is at
that time it wasn't until people really
understood what went on in Libby that it
was known that you could contract
asbestos related disease in this way I
mean it's always thought to be an
occupational disease in other words you
have to work around it for a long time
to get to get the disease but in Libby
there were no changing facilities at the
mine there were no showers so they the
miners all came home with dust on their
clothes and the dust was so toxic that
their wives and children got sick
and eventually there's just so much of
it all over the town that people had no
connection to the mine got sick so part
of it was medical knowledge but the fact
is the medical community didn't know
what was going on in 1959 the owner of
the mine started an x-ray program chest
x-ray program of the miners and they
found lung abnormalities in 130 miners
that first year
nobody told the miners the doctors in
town didn't tell the miners the company
didn't tell him and finally in the 80s
one doctor tried to blow the whistle and
got run out of town basically so that's
part of it the the mine ownership was
involved with the hospital board and it
was just all a very sort of internal
thing the other part of it is the
government that basically didn't do its
job both the state government who
discovered the asbestos in the or in
1956 and wrote reports that were
confidential shown only to the
management of the mine and the federal
government the EPA in 1975 of the
Scott's company that makes Scotts Turf
Builder and so forth in Ohio they were
using at that time almost a quarter of
the total production of the Libby mine I
had a huge operation there and their
workers started getting lung disease
started getting pleural effusion
bleeding in the lungs and EPA actually
came in and did a study and discovered
that it was because of the or from Libby
and that the or from Libby was toxic and
contained asbestos and that report got
stuck in a file drawer and was not
discovered rediscovered until after the
PI did the stories and the EPA sent an
emergency response team out there almost
two decades later and that team started
looking in their own records and found
that their own agency had covered this
up and the one plausible explanation for
that is that in the in the early 80s
there was something called the Grace
Commission which was a commission that
Ronald Reagan set up it was a run by a
bunch of businessmen specifically J
Peter grace who also owned the grace
corporation the random
but the grace grace Commission was
charged with getting government off the
backs of industry so called streamlining
government making government more
efficient and less intrusive and
somewhere in that process it got so
unintrusive that nobody ever did
anything about asbestos in Libya I mean
as far as I mean I wouldn't like I
wouldn't want to move there knowing that
history well you know one of the obscene
things about this is it's one of the
most beautiful places imaginable and one
of the prettiest places I've ever been
on this planet it's a beautiful spot but
you're right I mean it has definitely
affected the town and a lot of people
are really bitter about the publicity
sort of a slave and messenger situation
where you know our town was just fine
until people started nosing around in
this of course their people were dying
of it but that was you know they felt
that that nobody should have raised
raised a fuss about it
there are a lot fewer of those people
now since since after we did the stories
in the pie
the federal government came in and did
did this survey and found that almost a
third of the town has lung abnormality
so that I think really changed a lot of
minds in town
well you know that it's an interesting
story because when three days after our
stories came out
thank goodness for a guy named Bill
yellowtail who was then the region eight
EPA Administrator was a rancher from
Loyola Montana crow Indian amazing guy
anyway he was furious because we had
quoted the EPA's state coordinator as
saying this was strictly a personal
hygiene problem on the part of the
miners he just went nuts and he called
in a top top EPA emergency scene
coordinator and a team of an
epidemiologist and and a public health
doctor and they came in and started
looking and and discovered the problem
they thought that we were wrong they
thought it was a classic case of
journalists not knowing what they're
talking about and they found out that it
was actually worse than what we'd said
so that launched a cleanup the emergency
part of which lasted about three years
and now they're into what's called long
term remediation but they've spent 40
million bucks so far but they they're
not even close to getting it all cleaned
up and now just like a lot of Superfund
sites in the country the money's running
out from the federal government there's
a lot of pressure it's just like what's
going on with Hanford there's a lot of
pressure cut some corners clean it up
quick quick and dirty kind of approach
and so there's there's a lot of people
in Libby who were fighting that trying
to get the government to pay more
attention the head of the administrator
the EPA is gonna be in Libby next month
and that could be kind of an interesting
visit should be should be interesting to
see what happens well and in April of
2001 they declared bankruptcy right
before that they bought a company called
sealed air corporation makes like FedEx
pouches and mailing packaging stuff
small company they transferred billions
of dollars in assets to sealed air and
then they declared bankruptcy
fortunately the
EPA has something called forensic
accountants who basically are track
polluters finances and they took him to
federal court in Missoula and it looks
like that they're gonna get some of that
money I have access back to some of that
money but for a lot of people who filed
lawsuits obviously against grace right
now there's something in the in the
Congress called the asbestos Fairness
Act I prefer to think of it as the
asbestos industry Relief Act that
basically would make it a lot easier for
for all companies involved in in
asbestos to evade responsibility for for
part of it part of the problem is the
trial lawyers - I mean there are a lot
of frivolous that's best of suits out
there what they do is they run these
screening clinics and if you find a
shadow on your lung they sue everybody
who ever made asbestos and take a couple
thousand bucks and give it you know and
and take 30% of it or 40 so there's been
a lot of that and it's been an abuse but
the upshot of that is that a lot of
people who are truly sick and who have
had relatives die aren't getting
anything so it's big it's a big problem
and it's the [ __ ] thing to me is how
widespread it still is most people don't
understand that asbestos is still
perfectly legal in this country it's
legal to manufacture it products
containing asbestos to import it
whatever there was an attempt at banning
it in the 90s and it under pressure from
industry it got overturned and and the
government didn't didn't appeal it and
so there is no ban on asbestos in the
country today there's still s best us in
brakes most people most mechanics most
parts shop people don't think there is
there is in in a lot of breaks some some
not but there's there isn't some and
there's three quarters of a million
professional mechanics out there and a
lot of backyard mechanics who are still
at risk
we found asbestos we started testing
consumer products
as part of this investigation and we
found to our horror that there was
asbestos in crayons creoles a couple
other brands of american-made crayons we
couldn't believe it I mean we'd heard
that there was crate there's talc and
crayons and we knew there was a
specialist in some talc so we tested
something we couldn't believe the
results so we retested came up the same
way so we wrote a story saying there's s
best us in in crayons and it was like a
bomb went off as you can imagine you
know people talk about display the
messenger people were really upset with
us too for raising the possibility that
their kids crayons might have asbestos
oh but nonetheless the first thing that
happened was the the industry issued a
statement saying there is no asbestos
and crayons no we haven't tested for it
cuz it's not there and then then Binney
& Smith owns Crayola hired a so called
independent lab to to test the crayons
and they tested one crayon and came back
and said there was no asbestos in it and
then we wrote a story that said that the
lab they chose had made seven million
dollars testifying for the asbestos
industry so finally the government
stepped in we were really out on the
limb finally the government stepped in
after decades of doing nothing on
asbestos the Consumer Product Safety
Commission stepped in and did some
testing and found the same thing we
found and so within a week
all the major crayon manufacturers said
we'll take it out they did so we then
tracked back to try to figure out where
it came from
and it wasn't a talc and it was all from
a tout mine in upper New York in upstate
New York called the Vanderbilt talc
company and they had been fighting his
best us regulation for for many years
and continue to fight and continue to
mines health there and miners are
continuing to die there so it's really
all over in society it's interesting
yeah
legislation has been introduced to ban
it though well patty Murray thankfully
read our stories in the API she has she
has introduced a writer on Orrin Hatch's
asbestos Fairness Act that would ban
that would that would be a ban I think
its prospects for passage are not great
frankly I hope I hope it passes but I
don't think the odds are very good in
this Congress well it's hard to say I
mean it's certainly some I think they're
still wallboard being made it has it the
epa has tested various construction
project products and has has found it in
some I think the EPA's website probably
has some of that stuff listed I I think
that there is probably still semester's
and vermiculite products because I know
give you an example this mine in
Virginia Gracie used to own the property
there and they sold it because they did
tests and found out that the ore was
contaminated asbestos they sold it to a
guy who now owns the mine is now mining
it
he's a former assistant administrator of
the EPA he worked in the Nixon White
House he owns the mine for years and
years the Mine Safety and Health
Administration been doing inspections
there and finding nothing after some of
our stories came out the administrator
of M Shan or Clinton called us up and
said you know our agencies should be
disgraced for for what happened and
ashamed for what happened in Libya and
what's happening elsewhere and to make
sure it never happens again
they sent a surprise team of inspectors
into that mine and they found or up to
99 percent asbestos in that mine they
shut off some areas of the mine they
cited the mine they they warned the
miners told him to wear protective gear
they put warning signs all over the
place and on January 20th 2001
the cones came down the the warning
signs came down and that - - progressing
full-bore so I'd be very concerned about
products with that with vermiculite in
them lawn lawn products the big thing is
is to not expose yourself to the dust do
not dump the bag out and and and that
sort of thing
the the other the other real concern
consumer concern I think is the old
zonal light insulation from Libby is in
anywhere from 15 to 35 million homes in
the country it's loose fill insulation
it's in attics and it's it's not gonna
hurt you if it's just in your attic and
it's not coming through ceiling tile or
anything if it's if it's just in your
attic but as soon as you remodel as soon
as the cable installer goes up there as
soon as you you do anything that could
disturb it it gets in the air and and it
is very toxic it's a big problem
whenever a house like that is demolished
it's a problem so that's something to
really be aware of especially if you
have an older home I think so I mean if
they've done some some good things for
years and years there were piles of
vermiculite or downtown and Libby and
the kids would swing on ropes and land
in it you know it's like a big sandbox
and you know the ice rink at plummer
school and Libby was it was all
vermiculite underneath the track at the
high school was made out of vermiculite
the ball fields had it all over those
things have been cleaned up some of the
other areas have been cleaned up in town
there is still a lot of houses they gave
the stuff away free to people in town
for for insulation and for gardens and
so it's just all over the town as well
as what came out of they came in the air
you know so there's still a lot of
houses that need to be cleaned up and
but most of the public sites have been
cleaned up yeah they do and they've been
covered up how did the asbestos industry
get all of this political power in the
first place just randomly they just pay
people off I think it's it's you know a
big piece of it
take the Canadian piece the big there's
big asbestos industry in Canada it's not
that many jobs but the thing is it's in
Quebec and so it's become a sort of been
all wrapped up in in separatist politics
in Canada and so nobody wants to touch
the asbestos industry because it's it's
just basically a political sacred cow in
this country some of the major it's sort
of the big life theory it's like if
you're big enough you can get away with
it
these come a lot of these companies are
enormous companies they've been very
successful
Johns Manville Raybestos dresser
industries you know grace certainly one
of the biggest and the list is it's a
long list but it's basically a list of
it's a chunk of Corporate America and I
think it's just like any other situation
in the vanderbilt talc is a good example
they certainly had local senators and
congressmen doing their bidding because
it was a matter of jobs so question of
is the whole lobbying process a whole
political process really that's a
perfect example of it but it is really
an ugly piece of American corporate
history
doing anything to address this problem
and do the Clinton administration do
anything early to address that besides
what you're talking about Allegiant yet
well the answer is no and almost nothing
certainly the EPA under Carol Browner
and Clinton did not cover itself of
glory on asbestos there are a lot of
decisions that could have been made that
that or that went the wrong way
there are one thing that I certainly
learned comes through in the research we
did for this there are some wonderful
people in the government there are some
very dedicated people who are trying to
protect the public safety trying to do
their jobs and they basically are not
only at war with the polluters but they
are at war with their own higher-ups and
the agency in their war with the
administration certainly things got
worse after in the in the current
administration there's there's just no
denying that you know when 9/11 happened
the levels of asbestos that released in
the air in lower Manhattan are just
incredible and two days after 9/11
Christy Whitman stood in New York and
said the air is safe to breathe and
EPA's own research showed that it wasn't
ap a complete completely moon suit
workers the whole thing decontaminated
their own offices in Manhattan but
didn't do much for anybody else the if
you read it's hard not to get cynical if
you read the EPA's reports on a post
9/11 asbestos in Manhattan you read the
summary report you think everything is
pretty well handled and you read the
detail of the of the research and you
realize that the levels are very
dangerous
as a journalist are you encouraged to
follow up these kinds of story
because it seems like it's a public good
but you must have to do a lot of
research to get ones it's it's what we
do and and it's it's this is the great
thing I mentioned the PI's commitment to
this story I mean it's it's sort of our
responsibility to attack these kinds of
stories as well as the more the easier
the lower hanging fruit that we get the
paper every day you know it's it's
important that we spend some some
resources and some time doing this kind
of kind of working being a watchdog for
the public interest and I was very
fortunate in this case to have a
wonderful reporter an indomitable
reporter would not take no for an answer
on this story and having that kind of
expertise and being able to have the
commitment to the story is just what it
takes
I was just gonna ask not everyone in
Libby has s best ptosis who does have it
who's most susceptible to it well the
thing is nobody knows when the incidence
of asbestosis in Libby is even going to
peak the latency period of the disease
is so long that as part of the reason
that companies can you be a
responsibility it's part of the reason
you know that that it went unnoticed for
so long or unreported for so long in
Libya's because it's an old person's
disease I mean often people who get it
are in their 60s 70s but it is a truly
horrible way to die
and a very expensive way to die so it's
hard to say how many people will get it
as I say that there are somewhere
between 1,800 to 2,000 people who have
been diagnosed with lung abnormality in
Libby there may be more down the road
because there's still an exposure and
that's what frightens a lot of people
who are there looking at it the other
thing is that that the screening is
really a double-edged sword because once
people have gone through that screening
they can't get insurance if they if they
are found to have that it really affects
their ability good insurance and so
there's this huge almost incalculable
unfunded medical situation in Libby and
will be for many years
flanks not that I'm aware of no what do
you compare like the political power of
the asbestos industry to the tobacco
companies and the oil companies in terms
of special interest groups in the
government or use a very parallel
comparison I think it's a very apt
comparison but in terms of what's bigger
it's all it's I think it's wrong all of
a piece it's the same process is the
media doing its job on this beyond the
VI I mean um some certainly have you
know Spokane after we did this story the
the Spokane paper has followed up
there's a wonderful reporter in Spokane
and spent a lot of time on this story
there are others the New York Times has
been strangely silent on this story but
others have have done a good job with it
and I think we'll probably continue to
I'll be signing your book all right
thank you very much